oh yeah
that'd be so hot this scene is burned
in the minds of any kid who watched this
movie
in the 90s what if they did the stunt
and it landed backwards they're like
well dang that was cool
all right the rest of the scene they're
going back we're going backwards the
classic are you a dante's peak or a
volcano man
big thanks to skillshare for sponsoring
today's episode stick around to the end
to find out how you
can take the next step in your creative
journey hey what's up everyone welcome
back to another episode of visual
effects artist react we got freddy again
here today
and today we're going to be looking at
not just destruction but volcanoes
volcanoes are interesting because they
represent some of the things that are
very tricky and hard to do for visual
effects you have fire
you have smoke you have lava so you have
fluid simulations with liquids with
gas and then you have fire but very
different types of fluid simulations
it's the kind of thing that you couldn't
do on computers until recently
this didn't stop people in the 90s
trying to do them on computers to
varying degrees of success
yeah and you know what who doesn't love
watching things blow up volcanoes are
cool
don't even act like volcanoes aren't
cool volcanoes are cool you're scared of
volcanoes when you're kid you liar
you're scared of volcanoes and quicksand
we're not doing quicksand today we're
doing volcanoes
considering how little danger quicksand
actually ended up being i was far too
scared of quicksand but volcanoes though
get ready for some yeah
vfx welcome to the most extraordinary
and
unforgettable experience available on
this planet so the plot of this
is this guy wants to make a theme park
not with dinosaurs
but for an active volcano
dudes poor man's jon hamm yeah
no it's lucius malfoy it is that's
lucious malfoy he looks pretty
shocked for a guy who built a mega
resort
on a volcano
oh hello that was the prank one that
doesn't have glass on it
by the way there's a hot lava there with
no fire avoid the hot lava
in the middle everybody yeah there
should be fire and smoke coming up from
that hotline not necessarily here's the
thing nico when's the last time you
stood around glowing hot magma uh last
year when i went to hawaii and was there
smoke and stuff yeah
oh it's a 40. he's the authority on this
i feel so bad for that extra do you guys
see that extra just died dudes
extra on the right dies
[Laughter]
oh no another guy died guys look at the
second guy who dies oh
i did love that first lava drop that
just splattered and didn't bounce at all
in the camera i was like oh no it's just
right here nevermind
i need to see this guy get owned off of
this jet ski one more time
god yes i think if you got hit with
flying lava like that you would splatter
i don't think it would take your body
off just kidding i just i love the idea
that's like
he went off a jump like look at look at
this environment right now like
where are you going for a jump on your
jet ski at this time
a lot of the light wrap you can always
tell
a lot of light everything's glowy and
wrapping the light just everything just
super light wrap with the effects ours
just like take that light wrap slider
just
just kick it up keep going keep going i
want to see the thing glowing from the
outside
oh the effects break down here we go oh
that's not a little fun little rig there
they didn't fall back on like just mega
light wrap for him here either yeah
that's some good green screen work yeah
that's good okay how much of this how
much of this
like the docks everything everything
nothing was on fire they're getting
their reflections yeah they're getting
the reflections probably from the top
i'm not gonna lie it's cool seeing the
animation i would much rather see a shot
where they put down like
a couple hundred pounds of tnt and just
blow that tv yeah i just wanna see like
some pretty tnt explosions
what if they did the stunt and it landed
backwards they're like well dang that
was cool
all right the rest of the scene they're
going back they're going backwards and
they just like rearrange their whole
schedule to have the car go backwards
i mean that's basically what happened
with true lies when they did the shot
where the car
explodes and lands on the other side of
the bridge there's like well
we're sticking with that
wow
so what's going on the cascades picking
up some activity around dante's peak
now what do you think the odds are
against an eruption up there the classic
are you a dante's peak or a volcano man
you know the funny thing is i didn't see
either of them in theaters what
but i'm probably more of a tommy lee
jones man than a pierce bros than me
that's that's blasphemy pierce bros is
the hottest property in hollywood right
now
that looks really good whoa that looks
great
that was great that looks great i think
they blew some stuff up here for this
that looks really good this looks better
than sky fire i mean skyfire is way more
complicated yeah right but like there's
something
like the miniature work here is really
really good
don't look back
notice we all went right there i love it
we didn't do that at all for sky fire i
love it though
look at all the little little wood
particles and twigs oh that's cool
dude the timing detail there is like
just the middle of the house breaks
apart
all these miniatures
so it's worth noting that all of those
explosions that we were seeing were
probably straight up real
miniature but like practical filming
as opposed to digital vfx yeah i mean in
order to make miniatures look real at
this scale you have to shoot them in
slow motion you know if you want
something
that's small to look big you need to
slow things down so that gravity moves
at the speed it would move
if they got handy calculators for that
they do yeah in terms of like scale to
how much of a slow motion
you have to do so there's a lot of
copping work done in that shot when it
comes crawling around the mountain as
the camera goes up over the town they're
helping themselves as much as they can
because you got no
close trees poking up over the buildings
right just nice clean
flat roofs of buildings i am seeing a
soft mat around
the buildings in the billboard but
they're very selective that you know
it's everything's still hard edged for
the most part yeah it's the only shot
where the comping kind of betrays it i
want to know how they actually did the
the volcanic
ash wow there you go
that was it that was it okay so they're
probably just putting a huge
ton of ash in a giant bucket and then
throwing an explosion underneath it
looks like they're actually pumping air
out of it yeah actually yeah air
the secondary like curl vacuum on itself
looks so good
the base of the mound is going to be
about 100 feet wide wow that's a lot of
foam to carve
yeah slide it out of the aircraft
carrier wow
jeez it looks really good yeah how do
you even develop a skill to do this like
oh yeah i make full-scale
mountain models i mean it's a skill
that's in short supply these days for
sure
all the folks who would have gotten into
this are doing it on the computers so
the reason why all those pyroclastic
smoke
sims looked so good is because they
weren't simpsons actually they were
simulations
with the highest simulation settings on
the reality in reality
all right pull up volcano now volcano
also has some pretty crazy mention work
because they're doing a lot more with
lava
so what's interesting about volcanoes
what you see is you see a lot of
different types of things getting trying
to get comp together right wait
is that just straight up water that they
there's definitely
there's definitely a lot of miniature
like water stuff there's
stock footage of fire there's onset fire
like there's like three different colors
of
orange happening here you know and so
what they do get is the thick sort of
like
dappled magma stuff shots end up looking
really good
this is going to destroy everything it
touches
i am curious how they actually would
have gotten the actual like lava flow
you have like all the cooled off
sections of the skin essentially
that's like actually flowing and then
curling underneath the lava so that's i
mean
i assume they did that practically
somehow i think we got pulpit behind the
scenes on this i assume it's not
actually lava that's it the lava kitchen
so straight up it was it was practical
they were filming it but the fact that
they were able to nail the glow
are they lighting it from underneath no
they're using a black light to get that
glow
oh wow that's smart that's really smart
i love all these little solutions and
tricks i come up with
the thing that really sells the lava for
me is is the actual cooled off rocky
bits on top
yeah oh it's paint so they painted the
top of it yeah i mean that makes sense
because if they're literally like spray
painting on top that paint is gonna like
harden and then like kind of crack and
cake and so
that's just a layer of paint that's
dried up and is now just going to be
floating on top
very cool but it looks like they uh
miniaturized their sets basically and
blocked it out and then filmed it
yeah this is still requiring a lot of
like cg artists to sit down and
composite
this stuff onto the real footage and
then get all the fire in there but when
you start off with something that looks
very real
it makes the compositing much easier
sometimes that's a cg render that looks
very real other times it's a practical
thing
this scene is burned in the minds
of any kid who watched this movie from
blockbuster video in the 90s you talked
to anyone our age
we know this scene because it was so
visceral
[Music]
that's sweet this shoe is melting it
really sells
that the ground is hot
oh man oh man
oh man
something about the idea of knowing that
it's the ground and yet you're still
melting through it yes you should give
it a thumbs up at the end like the last
thoughts
going through your shock-addled mind
must be throw the thumbs it's like oh
this is the most intense pain i've ever
felt in my life
[Laughter]
hey if you guys aren't subscribed what
are you doing with your life
what are you watching this for subscribe
it's very simple and if you don't i'll
just be very disappointed in you as a
person
this mass suicide adhered to the mayan
calendar which predicts the end of time
to occur
on the 21st of december 2012 was an
awesome
theater movie it was so much fun the way
they brought this to life is just so
cool
it's starting
oh yeah that'd be so
hot it would be it's it's crazy how
fast heat travels i mean a big explosion
off in the distance you would feel the
heat from that on your face
instantly it's radiation
ah the shot i love this shot
good use like shockwaves and dirt and
then what are we tracking after all this
the rv in the middle of it good shot
see i think they're getting the impacts
a lot more accurate i mean who knows
but i think they're getting the impacts
a little bit more with like what i'd
want to see with like chunks of lava
hitting here i mean this is like the
granddaddy
of all things coming from the sky scenes
oh yeah love it not a single soft
feathered edge in sight no
it's a full cg probably oh yeah
i mean i think to me the thing that
really stands out when comparing this to
either dante's peak or volcano
is the fact that everything is unified
in the scene which is probably because
the scenes are almost 100 cg if not 100
cg but like you don't end up with like
fuzzy smoke edges that somebody's had to
mask out by hand
it's almost like one of those things
where it's like what domain are you
living in if you're living all in the
computer at least you have cohesion in
terms of that the moment you're trying
to pull together a bunch of different
elements it's just it's way harder if
you can do it well
it can look amazing but it's like that's
the risk yeah you know it's like let's
say you film some fire elements and you
film some lava elements and film some
smoke elements if your white balance
changed if your camera's changed if your
exposure changed
if any of that stuff changed your
elements now look different and they're
not going to perfectly match we see that
volcano when one fire is pink in the
other fires orange and one fire is
yellow and then it's white
you know you don't have that issue here
this shot right there i have a feeling
is actually mostly real right there as
the cracks start forming i think we're
popping over to maybe a projection of
the footage onto geometry
so it has that baked in lighting if they
were to do it fully cg i feel like i
would see
more interaction like that look at those
trees there they're not moving at all
as those explosions going around it so
they probably saved a little bit of
rendering time by just
using the actual plate footage but on
this next shot like as the whole ground
is starting to crumble now we're
starting to see
way more of the footage be completely
computer generated i wanna see the vfx
breakdown for this scene oh okay yeah
you're right yeah you're right
yeah it was real footage but it was you
know this it started where you said it
was right it was another 300 feet back
from where that shot actually starts
oh no you know what i mean it might be a
full-on helicopter shot actually
you're right yeah no that's a whole
full-on the whole thing was a big old
helicopter shot yeah but it's like the
lake there they had to have replaced
so much of the lake just because you
can't just have like a little bit of a
puddle
splash here because that's going to rip
off the whole thing has got to be
oh yep that's how they jumped it oh yeah
that was a good jump too with the rv
they had to rebuild all of the ground
around it obviously removing the ramp
how much of the dust from the actual rv
got left behind because i feel like
we're seeing
the color the contrast and the light is
a little different in the original
footage that i'm seeing here rather than
the final thing it's a little bit more
muted in the render i think they
probably tried to make it match the fake
smoke trails they did
yeah i just using it as a reference
otherwise it's a pain right because you
have a section of the smoke where it
hits the blue ramp
dude this guy must feel so good flipping
through like the previous and then to
the final shot
he's like yeah we did it there's so many
stages to make something like that work
for one you gotta shoot it well
two you gotta simulate a really cool
simulation of like the plumes
curling and all that stuff and then you
gotta light it well and render it and
hopefully that all works out well but
then it's still not married to the
footage so you have to composite it
add in all like the like the cool like
seams and stuff to make it all like
pop and all these things have to work in
a row and do visual effects
it's a totally illogical thing yeah this
is just like anyone who likes
simulations this is a movie for you
oh yeah this is yes it is a very fun
movie i've been searching my whole life
try to build up my database comment
below
any salmon based not just any fish
salmon specifically salmon based vfx
in the comments this is going to be the
central database depository of salmon
based vfx links i'm counting on all of
you to comment on those below don't let
freddie down
hey guys are you sick of trying to learn
things entirely on your own
sick of wafting in the unknown space of
not having anyone to guide you
or any wise teacher to come along and
say hey here's how you do this kid well
guess what all those problems are a
thing of the past with today's sponsor
skillshare if you're a lifelong learner
this is the product
for you you see skillshare is an online
learning community with
thousands of classes for creative and
curious people they have classes in
things like film and video
photography creative writing graphic
design illustration and more
one of my favorite classes that i've
taken recently is comedy filmmaking make
your low budget videos 100
funnier with amber schaefer she's
incredibly talented and she goes through
the process
of not only just how to write and create
a script that is funny but then how to
perform it edit it and present it in a
way that's also hilarious
one of the best things about skillshare
is that it's curated specifically for
learning
there's no ads and they're always
launching new premium classes
so you can stay focused and follow
wherever your creativity takes you
another great thing it's less than ten
dollars a month with an annual
subscription
imagine getting educated and how to do
anything creatively for less than ten
dollars a month
not bad so whether you're a creative
curious person
a lifelong learner a beginner dabbler
even a master consider skillshare
click the link in the description below
because the first 1000 people will get
30 off an annual premium membership this
works even if you've already had a free
trial to skillshare in the past
the community of creative people on
skillshare will be there waiting
oh boy i did not expect to watch so many
different volcano movies today
but here we are that was a lot of fun
this actually turns out and this is good
don't be scared volcanoes are still a
problem they're still volcanoes
all over the world have you seen any of
the footage from the icelandic volcano
right now yeah did you see the one where
they're like playing volleyball next to
it without a care in the world
you won't catch us 90s kids playing
volleyball around the corner like those
icelandic folks
you wanna know why because we grew up
with these films we grew up with dante's
peak
thank you so much for watching until
next time
be careful around any active volcanoes
yeah
then volcanoes you gotta don't trip also
check out the volcano park in hawaii
it's a trip